Ben: So, I'm going
to talk today about
the Chrome UI framework
that we use on Windows
called views,
how we build UI there,
how we test it,
and stuff like that.
And some more people's
coming in.
[clears throat]
So anyway, hopefully,
this will sort of give you
a broad idea of how
the framework works.
If you haven't used it before,
if you find yourself having
to do any UI development--
Maybe if you've even
already been using--
done all of the UI stuff,
but don't think that
the UI framework extends
beyond the status bubble.
That was a joke for Glenn.
But anyway, the view system
is basically--
it's a rendering system
and an event handling system
for drawing stuff into Windows
and handling events,
and stuff that happen in them.
So basically,
you have top-level windows,
and within them
you have individual controls.
And these things are--
we call them views.
And there's a base class
for all of them that is view,
in the view's namespace--
in the sky, he can paint
into a canvas,
he can receive events,
and do all kinds of things
in response to those.
So the views toolkit provides
some basic widgets
that allow you
to construct UI.
And all of these widgets
are just sub-classes of view.
And they override things
like Paint and other stuff
to do interesting things.
So the view itself--
all of the rendering
that we do in views is use Skia.
And so when we paint,
we paint into Skia canvases
and use some of the Skia
utilities to make things happen.
And so, if you've done work
on WebKit,
you might find that this
is somewhat similar to the way
rendering works within WebKit,
except much, much simpler,
because we don't have to,
you know, support things like
HTML, CSS,
and all that kind of stuff.
So basically, it's just
a very simple layout
and rendering system.
And so, I'll just tell you
a little bit about how it all
sort of fits together.
Like I said, we have
this view thing
that is like the individual
controls within a window.
The actual window itself
at the top level--
we have something
that we call a widget.
Which is--
on Windows, this is a hWnd.
Because in Windows,
eventually you have
to have an hWnd.
hWnd is what Windows thinks of
as the control.
And it doesn't know
anything else about
what else we might do.
So, we have this class called
Widget Win, on Windows,
which basically is responsible
for translating operating
system messages,
things like WMPaint,
WML button down,
all that sort of thing,
into things that
our view system understands.
And so this guy
has all these message handlers,
and he does that.
And the widget is responsible
for hosting a special kind
of view called a root view.
Maybe if I just come over here
and I'll just draw the structure
on this white board.
Oh, maybe Ian can--
So, Ian's just gonna turn
the camera around.
Okay.
Here we go.
So I've just drawn
some boxes here.
The outermost box is
the Widget Win.
So there would be,
you know,
when you're typically writing
Windows code,
you have your hWnd
and you might have child hWnds
and stuff like that.
Here is the Widget Windows,
the hWnd.
And inside that,
we have a single view,
which is a root view.
And the root view is a sub-class
of view that does some--
basically, it figures out
how to propagate events
and all that sort of thing.
So that sits there.
And then within the root view,
there is basically
the view hierarchy.
And so for the Chrome
browser window,
there is a fairly
deep hierarchy of views,
starting with the frame,
with the window
and all the way down
to individual buttons
and so on the toolbar.
And then dialogue boxes,
you end up with the same thing.
You know, there's the frame
with the dialogue box,
and then you'll end up
with individual buttons
and text fields and whatnot
inside that.
And so one of the most common
things that you will do
if you have to build some UI,
you might have to create
a dialogue box for something.
Maybe you're implementing
a new feature
and you need to configure it
or pop up something.
And so, we have a special kind
of widget
that is just for creating
a top-level window
or dialogue box,
and that's called Window.
And it's basically
a sub-class of widget.
And that provides you
with the ability to create
a top-level window,
and have all of
the right appearance,
the Chrome blue frame
and all sorts of other things
that sort of come
automatically.
And so you do that
in your code.
Basically, you create
one of these windows,
and you provide it
with something called
a window delegate.
And a window delegate
is this object.
It's an interface that you
implement on your object,
then you get notified of things
like the window is closing,
and you also get to configure
the window through
your implementation
of this interface.
Things like whether or not
you can be resized or maximized,
or things like that.
So by doing that,
you basically--
you tell the window
how it should look
when it gets created,
and also,
you can respond to events
that come from the window,
through your window delegate.
And typically,
the way this works is--
when you build a dialogue box,
you'll create a view
that is the contents
of your dialogue box.
And that will actually
be the thing
that sits in here somewhere.
And your view that--
your contents view
is actually your--in most cases
in the Chrome code,
it ends up being
the window delegate.
And that is able to respond
to the, you know,
closing of the things,
and it can go and configure--
it can go and, you know,
do things, you know,
when the window is closed.
Maybe you wanna perform an
action or something like that,
or scrape the state out of
any text boxes that you have,
and things like that.
Specifically for
a dialogue box,
we have some sugar on top of
a window delegate called
dialogue delegate
that supports being able
to create dialogue boxes
that have okay cancel buttons
and such.
And so that makes
that sort of thing a bit easier.
By the way, all this code--
if I didn't mention this before,
I probably should have--
is in the Chrome source
under source/chrome/views.
And there's some sub-directories
under there
that kind of organize this
into related sections.
So some of the stuff
that I was just talking about,
window, window delegate,
etcetera, is in view/window.
And there's a lot of
the other things around there.
And there's a controls directory
as well,
where you can find
the individual controls
that you can use buttons,
labels, etcetera, etcetera.
So I'll just mention
a couple of the controls.
I mean, most of them
will make sense
if you've ever done
any kind of UI programming
with any framework.
You know,
most of them make sense.
We have a couple
of interesting ones.
One is called hWnd View.
Sometimes you need to wrap
a native windows control.
Sometimes you just have
an hWnd.
And you need to put that
into your view hierarchy
somewhere.
And thing is, is that because
an hWnd isn't a Chrome view--
it is an hWnd.
It's not gonna get resized
automatically
per the layout rules
that you specify
in your view hierarchy.
So what we have is a control
called hWnd View
that basically allows you
to take any hWnd
that you might have--
say you have a--
I'll just use one example
of a renderer
or some other control
that you might have,
where you just have
the hWnd of it.
You can create an hWnd view
and attach the hWnd to it.
And from then on,
any time the hWnd view
gets resized,
it'll automatically size
the hWnd with it.
So that means that you can
basically have your hWnd,
your individual native hWnds
take part in the window layout.
And we have some other ones
like hWnd HTML view,
which is a specialization
of hWnd View
that allows you to specifically
embed a web rendering area
within your view hierarchy.
Now I just talked
a little bit about layout,
and that's something
that's kind of interesting.
A lot of the times when
you're building a dialogue box,
you might use one of the--
you might use
the existing layout manager,
like GridLayout,
which allows you to specify--
so you have a nicely lined up
arrangement of controls,
if you're putting something
together like that.
And there's some header files
around that define,
you know, nicely--
the nice aesthetic spacing
between controls
and stuff like that.
Sometimes you might be doing
something more specific,
more custom, things like
the top-level browser window,
for instance,
is not using a grid layout
because everything is very
specific to the individual case.
In this case for
your view method,
you just override layout,
and then you get to specify
each child's bounds
when your layout method
is called.
Layout is called automatically
by the framework
whenever the top-level widget
is resized.
Basically, it goes down through
the hierarchy calling layout.
And then basically
each child view--
each view has a layout called,
and then it goes and sizes
its children.
And when the children's
bounds change,
it calls layout and it
just propagates like that.
So part of that--
there's another method
that you might override
sometimes called
Get Preferred Size.
And the preferred size
of your widget
is basically the size
that you want your view to be
when it's layed out.
So you might say that your view,
wants to be, you know, 20 x 30,
and then when that view's parent
is called,
it might call
Get Preferred Size
and then size that
and position it,
and stuff like that.
So that's something else
that you might find you do.
I just figured I'd talk briefly
about the construction
of the top-level window
as well.
Sometimes you see some of these
things in your call stack.
It might be interesting
to know what they are.
Like I said before,
and I drew my diagram
of it here,
the top-level Widget Win window
is the container,
the native hWnd that contains
the view hierarchy.
Top-level view is a root view.
Then inside that,
in every single case these days,
the only child
of the root view
is something called
a non-client view.
And this kind of maps to
the window's concept
of client and non-client
rendering.
On Windows, when you have
a non-client area,
this is the area that is
the frame of the window,
the title by the sizing border,
stuff like that.
And then inside that,
you have a client area,
which is the contents
of the window.
So it kind of replicated
that here in the view system.
The non-client view contains
the client view,
and it also contains a--
what we call a frame view,
which actually renders
the blue border around
the window.
And so--
and that can do
all of the specific
functionality for that.
And then the client view
is the thing
that actually contains
the contents.
So I should have simplified this
a bit before
when I was talking about
dialogue boxes,
and I said that you would make
a contents view for your--
had the controls
of your dialogue box,
and that would go
into the window.
That actually goes inside
of client view.
You don't actually get to see
any of this.
It's all hidden behind
the call to create Chrome window
that you make.
But the client view is the thing
that basically--
in the case of a dialogue box,
the client view provides
the Okay and Cancel buttons,
and stuff like that.
And you may find that,
you know,
you find yourself in there
sometimes
if you're trying
to figure something out.
So just a general high-level
comment about the way that
the front end is being developed
primarily because--
all the stuff I've talked about
so far
is related to UI that we've been
building on windows.
But we are a cross-platform
project.
And so there is
a lot of logic
that is shared
between platforms.
And you'll find that there are
a lot of objects
within the browser front end
that are actually
cross platforms.
Things like browser,
tab content, stuff like that.
And so we didn't want
to tie them too closely together
with our windows implementation
of the front end,
so we used the sort of
the standard approach
for this in model view
controller layout, where--
we consider some of
the state objects like browser,
tab contents, etcetera,
to be the state of the model
in this case, and then the--
all of the Chrome view stuff,
that's kind of the--
that's sort of the view
controller side of things.
And what this means is that
we can separate out this model
and we can actually use that on
Mac and Linux,
which is what we're doing.
And also because there isn't
this sort of type coupling
of that particular UI state.
And it's also a lot easier
to write unit tests
for the model.
And I'll get to that
in just a moment.
Actually, I'll get to that
right now.
So because the--
like I said,
because it separated it out,
it's been more possible
to write more unit tests.
Sometimes you have a relatively
simple state object,
and you can just write
a regular unit test for it
using the existing
unit test framework
and get that to work.
Sometimes you wanna do something
a little bit more complicated,
and you wanna test functionality
that goes out and loads pages,
you know, off a test server
and stuff like that.
So we have a thing called
in-process browser tests
that basically allow--
that basically spins up
a message loop
and allows you to simulate
running the actual browser,
but in a unit test.
And these are pretty easy
to write.
We're still getting
some of the kinks
worked out of the system,
but they're still pretty easy
to write and run in isolation.
And finally, we have UI tests
which are much higher level,
very deep sort of tests
that basically run
the whole browser
in a separate process.
Basically, to run the browser
as a user would.
And it sends commands to it
through an automation API.
I would recommend if
you're writing new features
to write most stuff
as unit tests
or in-process browser tests
'cause these are the easiest
to debug.
But if you want to get--
if you want something to run
on Chrome Bot
or any of these other things,
you would need to write UI
tests, and automated UI tests.
So that's sort of a brief
summary of the framework.